uh for you we've been getting singles
yeah is there an album on the way it's
definitely out on the way okay I haven't
started it yet I mean I got over two
thousand three thousand records in the
hard drive but Jesus I don't feel like I
started on the album yeah like the Tupac
r b with your unreleased [__] man that's
crazy I was just my my boy my DJ was
telling me he was like yo just send me
all your records and let me put together
an album like let me see what I was like
that could be fun actually that could be
fun that could be dope you know what I'm
saying but yeah I I haven't I haven't
started on the project yet so there's
only one more single after this one and
then
um no there's gonna be tour single
another single
tour one more single and then a project
like I'm just really sit down and work
on music so tell me about the tour
so the tour Neil hit me a couple months
ago you know he's like I'm doing this
tour he's one of my last major projects
I'm putting out and I'm on a tour I want
you to be on the Champagnes and Roses
tour with me I was like all right it's a
short tour it's short and sweet but it's
fire me him and and Robin Thicke I feel
like we all have overlapping audiences
for sure and um try to ride I just feel
like it's a lot of Classics records
being sung on that tour you know and
it's a great Army tour so and all you
all you guys that think are single right
um
you know
no
it's actually the opposite I don't know
we outside though well I'm not trying to
like I don't know if Neo's business but
I know he got divorced recently and then
I think Robert amen Leo's Neo man all
I'm saying is that those those listen
those backstage situations outside man
we outside and it's lit life is good man
I think like
I think when it comes to like being an
artist and being in a relationship I'm
private with my [__] I just I don't want
people to see when I [__] up so you're
so private you're in a committed I'm
just telling you that I'm private in my
life because if I [__] up I don't want
nobody to know I respect that and then
you have to have well you also I'm not
about to put me on like a shade room or
whatever well you have to have that um
did you see um God Bless The Soul Man
shout out to little meech man he got
costume which I want ring cam which I
won't [__] up did you see black man
don't cheat huh did you see what
happened with little meat man he had to
yeah you see the invisible groceries I
saw the invisible groceries man I think
that somebody what happened was because
this happened to me before what happened
was somebody you know I'm saying
Photoshop the groceries out of his hand
you're probably right I'm saying yeah he
had Grocery and like listen it's like
man Define groceries like maybe he had a
candy bar in his pocket that he was
helping that young lady obviously his
cousin yeah I love summer Walker man
she's fighting she's a legend she's
she's fired I mean she's a young goat
you know he's doing his thing it's it's
stuff out here I don't EMF
yeah I watched it a few times I haven't
watched BMF I haven't gotten into it
yeah I don't watch a lot of TV like that
so fun I ain't got enough time to watch
TV like you all right it's hard for me
to like sit and binge watch anything bro
right now I'm like so like in this mode
of like all right create yeah just like
just working literally like on the road
all the time every weekend I'm out of
town if I'm not out of town I'm like
doing some other [__] to prepare for
something else like it's just you know I
don't really have time to watch TV uh
what's the last show you did binge watch
um the last show I did been watched was
you I like crazy [__] some crazy [__]
yeah I like I like Twisted dark [__]
that has something some beautiful like
silver lining in between it I just like
that because that's not my life have you
ever been you level obsessed with a
female in your life one thousand percent
wow every time well not I'm I'm an
obsessive type of dude I ain't gonna lie
like I like I obsess over what I love
Yeah
unhealthy you're not like out here
murdering people nah I can't
um get away with it but if if like at
the end of the day I'm obsessive about
what I like for sure guaranteed yeah no
that's uh that's a wild show and then
you know it's crazy if you ever I don't
know if any of your female friends are
into uh
these uh True True Detective type shows
like the [__] for like my wife is
into these murder mystery like
documentary shows that are on Hulu yeah
it's all that gets played on my house
and I just be like it's always women
getting away with killing their husbands
what are we doing here are you trying to
apply something what the [__] going on
here you know what I'm saying that's
crazy